saint rémy les chevreuse ville connue
pour sa quiétude et ses commerces de
proximité mais depuis plusieurs mois ils
sont la cible de cambriolages et
dégradations de vitrines des
cambriolages parfois rudimentaire les
délinquants ont cassé la porte d'une
pharmacie de la ville avec des
casseroles d'autres vitrines ont été
brisées avec des pierres ces délits sont
commis la nuit à saint rémy les
chevreuse terminus du rer b par des
personnes se présentant comme mineur il
y avait des jeunes qu'on essayait de
vouloir entrer dans la boutique ma porte
elle est morte elle est hs en tassant
faut tout changer le ballon le global et
une fois je suis sorti donc il y avait
avait le traiteur était déjà dehors il y
avait un voisin aussi qu avait alerté
parce qu il l entend du bruit au sik
habite à côté de chez moi donc après ils
ont été interpellés un peu plus tard par
la police mais après ils ont été jugés
mais relâché après la justice des
mineurs oppose sur un texte l'ordonnancé
du 2 février 1945 le maire a rencontré
la ministre de la justice pour une
révision de cette ordonnance
en france le seuil d'âge de
responsabilité pénale n'est aujourd'hui
pas précisément fixée la ministre lui a
fait part de son futur code de justice
pénale des mineurs
elle prévoit d'instaurer le seuil à 13
ans en dessous de 7 à celle des mesures
éducatives seront prononcés cette
réforme ne sera mise en vigueur que dans
un an le 1er octobre 2020 premières
préconisations quand ils sont identifiés
et qu'on connaît les pays d'origine de
travailler avec les pays d'origine pour
les renvoyer dans leur famille
deuxième point traiter mieux la récidive
il est une autre disposition qui vise à
mieux indemniser plus rapidement les
victimes pour que les victimes qui
attendent des fois jusqu'à 18 mois pour
avoir gain de cause sur l'organisation
ça soit fait sur un délai de trois mois
autre point du futur code de justice
pénale des mineurs 20 centre éducatif
fermé pour mineurs vont être créés en
france